اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اجراء جديد ضد
الفلسطينيين اسرائيل تصادم 32 مليون دولار
من عائده الضرائب للسلطه الفلسطينيه
وتواصل عمليات الهدم في الضفه الغربيه هذا
في حين نادت
باغلاق منازل لعائله فلسطينيه مشيره الى
ان ذلك يرقى الى مستوى جرائم
واسطه تحذيرات اوكرانيه من حشد روسيا نصف
مليون جندي على الحدود الشرقيه لشن هجوم
واسع جديد القاده الاوروبيون يتوافدون على
كيف لعقد قمه او رقيه اوكرانيه
يطلب مزيدا من الدعم لقواته وبوتين يقول
ان الغرب يحارب روسيا على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ويهددها بدبابات لبارده
الالمانيه مخيمات النازحين شمال غرب سوريا
تتعرض لاضرار متفاوته بسبب الثلوج
والامطار الغزيره التي ضربت المنطقه منظمه
منسق واستجابه السوريه قالت 49 مخيما تضرر
وان مئه وتسعين عائله حرموا من الماوى
جراء تضرر المحتوى الداخلي للخيانه
البرلمان الكندي يوافق على مقترح لاستقبال
10 الاف لاجئ من الايغور فرو من الصين
وتوطينهم على مدى عامين وذلك بعد سنتين من
وصف المشرعين الكنديين معامله بجين
للاقليه المسلمه في اقليم ماشينغ بانها
اباده جماعيه الى اللقاء